il est catastrophique c'est tout
je suis stressé pour le début de cette
vidéo j'ai vraiment envie d'être bon et
de progresser dans le dessin c'est le
thème de cette vidéo ça faisait
longtemps n'est ce pas souvenez-vous en
2014 j'avais fait dans quelques vidéos
des dessins enfin chaque année en
réalité je fais toujours une vidéo qui
tourne un peu autour du dessin sauf que
je me concentre plus sur faire des
blagues et c'est pour la vidéo que sur
le dessin pour ceux qui n'avaient pas vu
c'est le dos là l'époque et qui sont sur
la chaîne depuis peu de temps je vous
fais un petit débrief bon père est
quelqu'un qui adore la photo la vidéo et
le dessin et qui est bon dans l'es3 et
lorsqu'il a eu deux enfants il a décidé
de donner 100% de son gène du dessin à
mon frère florent ça se voit regardez
c'est plutôt joli
j'ai toujours eu énormément d'admiration
pour ceux qui savent dessiner parce que
je comprends vraiment pas du tout
comment c'est possible et comment ça
marche et quand et comment vous en
faites aux mamelles ils font des dessins
photos réalistes photo réaliste avec une
feuille à un craignons ça me troue le je
suis désolé on a la chance on vit dans
une époque où il ya beaucoup de progrès
technique et serra et où il ya l'accès
au savoir la facilité grâce à internet
et toutes les infos du monde tout ce
dont on a besoin sur internet pour
apprendre les bases d'un million y
compris les bases du dessin aujourd'hui
je vais suivre les tutos nouvelle
génération la pointe de la pointe un
tuto qui sont sortis en 2019 et aussi en
2008 des tutos vraiment et c'est
quelqu'un qui t'expliquent de a à z
comment faire il ya même des petites ce
taux qui sont sortis pour apprendre en
vingt secondes en quelques traits à
faire un truc super bien incroyable
aujourd'hui je fais le pas avec vous
d'essayer de développer ce problème
décès de débloquer quelque chose j'ai
quelques tutos sous la main je vais les
suivre devant vous ça peut-être méga
chiant je sais pas à cette vidéo mais
j'avais envie de la faire voilà soyez
indulgents encourager mois merci ça m'a
beaucoup motivé allons-y premier tuto
celui-là il a ainsi tourné il m'a fait
rire rire parce que quand je vois je
suis tellement nul que quand je vois un
tuto pour dessiner je me sens offensé
j'ai un besoin de la personne et
arrogante avec moi qu'elle me prend de
haut c'est chaud quand même comme je
suis sur la défensive vis-à-vis de ça
c'est un vrai complexe qu'on soit clair
ici c'est un tutoriel pour dessiner une
main en 15 secondes les gens et demain
vraiment belle
[Musique]
mais quel culot de faire ça me prenait a
décidé une morgue 1 seconde bande de
gros nul ou regarder c'est simple arrêté
d'être arrogant là les dessinateurs
aller j'y vais mais ça ressemble
ça ressemble s'assemble atsé la plante
des fois qu'il ya dans les champs mais
pas du tout à une main mais c'est normal
il manque d'être et qui ensuite tu relis
tous déjà pourquoi il ya de l'air entre
et très peu fait pas du tout respecté à
un trait qui va là comme ça et là les
deux poules doivent se rejoindre
avec le tri qui parle ici et ça fait le
buzz la moins au nom j'ai envie de
pleurer
ça me fait vraiment bizarre parce que
vous savez quand vous sortez d'un
contrôle et vous dit [ __ ] j'ai bien
géré je suis content j'ai réussi et que
corps vous rend la copie vous avez cac
sur 20 c'est exactement ce que je viens
de vivre en suisse du tout mais j'ai un
problème de géométrie dans mon cerveau
que j'ai même pas de comparaison à faire
avec un truc qui existe c'est bel et
bien une main mais le problème c'est
qu'elle a une jambe
le problème c'est qu'elle a une [ __ ]
jo regarder si je fais un pied on me dit
croître regardez je vais rajouter une
chaussure ça fait vraiment une main
quartier dessin suivant bon là c'était
une petite mise en misant mise en bouche
savez c'est comme quand tu le restaurant
et compte faire un petit appetizer qui
n'a pas demandé ces cadeaux c'est
gratuit ça tombe sur le coin du nez puis
tu es content quoi messieurs dames on
s'attaque à un vrai délire nous allons
apprendre à dessiner bien avant de voir
du tout je vous montre comment moi je
fais un oeil donc commencer par faire le
sourcil voilà rien de compliqué moi
comme j'ai appris à l'époque donc
c'était à très longtemps c'était environ
il ya 18 ans et tu fais un rebond après
sa renommée en mode manga pas réaliste
et après on fait ce que je fais c'est je
faisais des ronds comme ça comme s'il y
avait des reflets dans l'oeil
et là en fait je colorées autour ça se
trouve déjà fait dans une vidéo et j'ai
totalement oublié en raison des
problèmes de mémoire c'est totalement
possible
et voilà et là on a un oeil une note
pour l'oeil de squeeze hausse hier déjà
plus que sur moi maintenant voyez pas la
différence
bayne à l'ewi annonce plutôt de merde ça
va encore être un truc qui m'énerve
oui oui je vais faire ça tu as raison tu
as raison tu t y va se terminer je vais
montrer la feuille aura sa dessus c'est
bon pour vous préférez lequel je connais
la
ok ok ok et a peint un rond pas où c'est
parti
pas mal or on en a levé en réalité étape
2 le deuxième round house
pourquoi j'ai voulu faire cette vidéo
pourquoi je vais simplement de mettre
tous les dessinateurs de france à dos ok
troisième étape
ok en bas bombe à l'ancienne un doublé
ma règle qu'est ce que je fais j'utilise
ça je vous jure je m'applique vraiment
je fais pas des blagues gens c'est un
vrai cours d'eau descendant vidéo suis
plutôt chiant mais au moins dites vous
que moi lorsque je dessine vous vous
pouvez atteindre ce résultat parce que
vous êtes voilons meilleur que moi mais
je suis un truc mais je suis un truc
mais que je peux plus m'arrêter montrer
je suis sur un truc de ouf il est bien
calculé
mais qu au nom il passe pas ses prix de
l'oeil non bon bah au moins ya des hauts
et des bas dans cette vidéo il encore
trop loin je refais pourquoi j'ai ce qui
n'allait pas et c'est la même chose qui
ne va pas ok c'est bon c'est bon c'est
pas parfait mais ça va ok la suite ça
vous dit un truc ça vous n'êtes pas
l'impression qu'elle a copié de
quelqu'un ce truc là on dirait bien que
les grands esprits se rencontrent donc
là je dois faire ça ok allez
[Musique]
ok des petits bâtons de forme
irrégulière tout autour de l'oeil ça a
l'air très dur parlant de satan ça fait
tout mec sait les risques quoi ça fait
tous ok je crois oui la technique j'ai
compris c'est un grand un petit peu un
grand petit plus petits plus régulier en
tout cas je vous dis je m'applique là
c'est vraiment pas georges veux pas
faire un truc dégueulasse volontairement
pour être drôle je veux vraiment faire
un beau truc pour montrer que finalement
le dessin est un art accessible à tous
et à toutes
ah ouais ok mais j'ai pas de coton tige
attends je m'appelais lorraine ouais il
me faut un coton tige pour faire l'oeil
là ouais c'est du dessin mais il faut
des outils de make-up une fois consenti
chaud elle m'a dit bâle prend du pq est
mêlé au bout d'un crayon aller
[Musique]
c'est tellement de stress pour un si
petit truc pour un high tech c'est même
pas vrai dessin c'est un oeil hiatus
l'oeil mecque le problème de ça c'est
tout le problème de moi et du dessin
c'est que faut être hyper précis dans ce
qu'on fait on pas en foot partout pour
ce soir à cordes ce soit joli mais moi
c'est parce que je propose dans la vie
ok c'est pas mal de gens du ce qu'ils
veulent mais c'est pas ma montre aux
[ __ ] un nouveau trait c'est quoi sa
hausse et les s'il ya besoin de revivre
le truc des doigts on dirait qu'elle
fait les doigts de l'autre tuto faut pas
qu'ils aillent exactement dans le même
sens ou qu'un exploit non plus comme ça
fonctionne plus comme ça un peu plus
comme ça ça y est je sais moi je
commence à comprendre mais non mais là
les les galeries d'art sont pas prêtes
[Musique]
si beau si j'arrive à faire ça ça va
tout rattrapé à temps oh c'est bon les
démarches taj et la pression parce que
je sais que là je peux tout gâcher au
moins de trucs là franchement mais
regarde à côté de moi
on s'en rend compte de la beauté tu de
ça je suis vraiment content au québec
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal an plus tard
le sourcil alors là c'est pas le moment
tout cas chez moi je vais vous dire
c'est pas du tout le moment tout gâcher
avec le sourcil je sais je sais que vous
êtes pris par la vidéo comme de voir un
bon match de foot vous savez vous dites
moi mais qu'est ce qui va se passer quel
rebondissement va encore y avoir quelle
est la prochaine étape est lui va-t-il
réussir l'étape je sais vous êtes dedans
ou peut-être que je dis ça pour me
rassurer parce que je doute sur la
qualité de la vidéo c'est possible aussi
[Musique]
un mec j'ai géré la forme ok ben hammam
les petits très au-dessus ok on mais
l'épaisseur c'est la mode en plus les
sourcils imposant
[Musique]
hop là j'ai fini avant toi la pire
manière de suivre un tuto attend 90 ans
il ya juste un truc qui va pas vous en
faites pas
j'aurais jamais dû faire ça j'aurais
jamais dû être ainsi sa marche ouah je
crois que j'ai fini mail jeu alors je
vous assure que ça me fait une petite
émotion messieurs dames voici mon oeil
après 1h04 de travail précisément
[Musique]
j'aurais pas dû dire le temps que j'aime
bien le faire je l'a pas dû dire le
temps c'était vrai parce que les gens se
sont dit une heure c'est non mais non on
fait des dissertations en une heure
quoique non ça fait longtemps que je
peux aller à l'école a effectivement
allez vous me donner ma petite note
soyez franc billets pas même si je suis
petit mais que ces axes de me vexer
grandement sié souleymane bamba vous
avez lancé après noté bon on sait faire
une main on sait faire un oeil ce qu'il
est patent maintenant de dessiner le
rêve de toute personne un chip à il vous
allez en réalité je pars chez les tout
cas faire mais je veux maire de bages
fait un si bas et vous allez pourquoi
c'est bien parce que la nuit porte
conseil
allez à demain pour l'épreuve finale
[Musique]
deux semaines son passé deux semaines
sont passées avant que je me décide à
tourner la suite de la vidéo et aux as
et pourquoi parce que j'ai repris en
boucle beaucoup beaucoup la suite
monatte j'espère te faire honneur en
dessinant un petit chiba et nous
pourrons comparer ensuite directement
aux modèles ici présents orly mais cause
iam
allez on y va première étape fait quatre
petites marques pour indiquer la largeur
et hauteur des cercles
moi je suis bon en servent qu'on a vu un
pour l'oeil je suis assez bon en scène
donc je n'en fais pas un il faut les
faire assez collé à ses côtés puisque
sinon le chiba il aura un trop grand or
vous hanter arrivée vous hanter l'erreur
arrivé à loisy jb - spa ou celui-là il
pas ouf à [ __ ] j'ai oublié la gomme je
passe mon temps à gommer c'est infernal
résumait que je vais faire les services
offerts ce qu'il a dit c'est débile
il a vraiment pas talent lui pour faire
des marqueurs avant de faire un cercle
qui a vraiment besoin de ça tous les
bons dessinateurs ont fait pas comme ça
déjà donc regard je te montre comment
enfin c'est avec mon pote et tu me dis
ce que tu en penses
voilà et devant lé deuxième un peu plus
petit est collé
parfait voilà allez petit marqueur ça
sert à rien écouté les conseils de
squeeze sur le haut fait un autre sert
pour la tête est mais ça y est sur un
trend qui fait il a fait le juste que je
m'en remets dedans est en train de qu'il
fait ok troisième cirque fait moment on
a une sorte de mickey décapité mais ça
va devenir un chiba étape 5 fait un
petit cercle et on l'utilisera comme
guide pour le museau ok il est bien il
est bien il est bien alors on vous l'a
peut-être dessiné deux petits triangles
ouais c'est vrai qu'on s'est vraiment
des patates
elles sont vraiment beaucoup trop ronde
aux extrémités genre de l'ema pas mal
pas mal pas mal pas mal pas mal c'est
pas mal
allez on avance en dessous le cercle sur
la gauche fait un dessin avec deux
grandes lignes pour faire le devant des
pâtes
ok donc là en fait on est en train de
finalement de faire tout ce qui va être
liés aux proportions c'est rigolo ce
truc de faire juste savoir toutes les
proportions nickel et ensuite mettre les
détails c'est marrant et mais qui est un
bon début de chiba est allé soit pas day
est ce que toi tu as fait un tube avec
ces proportions là les tiennes était
bien meilleur à l'infini pour les lignes
qui vont nous guider
elle a raison les yeux en amande un spa
des rondes en bonbons ses parents je
t'en mets pas dans le coup ça devient si
dur
what the fuck c'est trop dur j'ai visé
trop haut mext rhodia annonce aiea une
paire de morale il ya une paire de
morale du côté le dessinateur français
non mais regarde les détails non samsung
salies pts en fait en fait ce qui me
saoule c'est quand ça va bien ça va mais
jamais faisons tous un effort
d'accord je vais vous demander qu'on
fasse tous un effort cette adresse pas
mal pas mal pas mal pas mal il va être
pas mal à temps je reprends un peu
confiance
je suis en train d'y arriver il fait
magnifique de chiba il va être
magnifique
je vous le dis étape 15 allez on arrive
à la moitié de la moitié les oreilles
oui je suis plus oreilles que dieu m'en
voyez ça se voit ok ok la tête de
rochers à ça fait mal je m'en fous gérer
au bout je m'en fous m'en fous j'ai là
au bout mais c'est dur quoi en fait
c'est sur des rencontres en train de
faire une vidéo pas du tout satisfaisant
j'attends une vidéo horriblement peu
satisfaisante mon excuse attendait en
chantant leur bon goût je pense que mon
schéma il va pas être si mal comme chez
moi il va pas être si mal je vous le dis
sur l'appareil pour faire le fil à les
petits traits comme ça pour montrer
qu'elle étouffe le fait que tout mimi
suite à ces petites griffes voyait pas
tu me fait que l'autre mais c'est par
ici peut s'être blessé à la patte en
allant à la chasse par exemple
passé avec eux au [ __ ] là que mec là
je veux faire honneur à nice ou pour toi
c'est pour toi n'être là que la bien
fluffy bien mignonne là qui convainc
l'acheteur de chiba d'acheter l'eau
chiba mais robert troubler les baisses
une belle que bon mais ces dames après
avoir effacé les lignes de départ est
retouché ce qu'il fallait
attendez j'ai un discours mais je pas
prêts à gérer mais nous obtenons ceci
vous savez pourquoi vous plaît pas parce
qu'il ya pas les ombrages on va les
faire maintenant et vous allez voir ça
va tout changer
[Musique]
messieurs dames le résultat a pris
ombrage est assez spectaculaire 50
minutes pour ça il a la tête que vous
faites en ce moment même en découvrant
le résultat je sais pas comment j'ai
fait pour passer de ça à ça ça n'a pas
de sens
jamie c'est la fin de cette vidéo dessin
j'espère avant tout qu'elle vous a plu
je vous avoue mettre vraiment étonné sur
cette oeuvre réellement j'en suis fier
vous promets de taille je suis vraiment
content du résultat en fait j'ai
repoussé beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup le
tournage de la suite de la vidéo parce
que chez avec le schéma salle est une
step by step supérieur lui le gars il a
un très haut - l'ombre âge mexes et
gribouillis c'est dégueulasse lui la
personne là elle a tellement gérer les
ombrages c'est tellement bon ben voila
voila je vous fais un débrief sur juste
une est dans merde qui veut se mettre au
dessin est un mec il dessine bien après
je pense que tous ceux tous les gens qui
décident extrêmement bien aujourd'hui
sont passés par cette étape
sauf qu'il n'avait peut-être pas 23 ans
et c'est ça qui fait mal j'espère en
tout cas à défaut d'avoir réussi à faire
de beaux dessins j'ai réussi à vous
divertir dans cette vidéo j'aurais
vraiment tout donné dans cette vidéo
mais je pense de toute manière que c'est
le travail qui paye et que si j'essayais
de faire ça tous les jours ou plusieurs
fois par semaine va au bout de au bout
de quelques années j'aimerais avoir un
petit level en dessin n'hésitez pas à
suivre les mêmes plutôt que moi je
mettrais les deux liens en descriptions
et à me m'envoyer une photo du résultat
sur twitter allez à bientôt
merci tout le monde je vais encadrer cet
oeil et déchiré le schéma attendez
attendez ce n'est absolument pas comparé
à part dont allez à bientôt kevin
tchèque
[Musique]